- I like the music.
- Thank you.
It was so hard because I'm
always so worried about score.
It always feels a little
too old and I don't know.
You know how score is.
It's like an overlay,
all of a sudden on your,
it's like someone else dressed
your child in crazy clothes.
- You're right.
But this is kind of
friendly, energy, and fun,
but you don't go, "Oh,
there's that tune again."
You're just like, "Yeah, that's pleasant."
(audience laughing)
- Well, if you like it,
then I feel good because
your ear, you're a music man.
And so I'm very relieved to
get your blessing on the song.
We've actually--
You know what--
- Drew, can I go?
- Yes. (laughing)
- Come on!
All right, you go.
- Oh god, I know, sorry.
It's the Zoom thing.
I was watching this movie and
I'm taking all these notes,
and all I keep thinking is
there's just not anything like this.
- Drew, I'm telling you, the whole thing,
we kept saying we wanted
to do a Halloween movie.
I remember when I was a kid
and Charlie Brown did a Halloween special,
and it was like, it was
the greatest thing ever
that you had something
dedicated to Halloween.
We kind of wanted to make a movie
that hopefully every year they go,
"Oh yeah, let's watch "Hubie Halloween"
"and get in the spirit."
It was shot in Salem.
We all brought all our families there,
and the whole town was
decorated for Halloween.
We just had a nice time together.
- When I came to visit you up in Boston,
you said something to
me that stuck with me,
and you were like,
"I still am happy when kids come up to me.
"I'm still happy when
I'm talking to people."
It just made me so happy.
The humanity of what you do,
it still burns in your heart.
- Drew, that's for sure.
When you're making a movie like this,
I'm thinking of these kids
and I'm thinking of these,
I want families to have a good time.
I want every age to laugh,
but when a little kid comes up to you,
and calls you by the
character's name from the movie
and kids come up to me while I'm eating,
I'll stop eating and hang out with--
By the way, it's very hard
for me to stop eating,
you know that.
But I will stop eating
and talk to the kids
as long as they want to talk.
- By the way, I just got so excited.
There was like a hot debate on Twitter
about you, me, and Aniston.
- Yes. I heard about this, Drew,
and you told me that it was fun.
That's Jennifer Aniston right there.
You see how you did it with a picture?
- Yeah. Yeah.
We have that technology.
Of course the picture I'm
referring to you, me, and J
is literally a Polaroid.
- I know, we had fun with J, by the way.
But yes, and Drew, I remember
you crossing your eyes
for that picture.
And remember, that stuck
for about four days.
(laughing)
Yeah. I love that.
I love you. And you know I
love Aniston and so do you.
We're all great friends.
And some debate that sounded nuts to me.
- I loved it because what I
wanted to do is respond to say,
I would pick her too.
And let everyone know
that we all are kind of like a triangle
and there's not only no
competition, but so much love.
And then I thought about doing something
with you, me, and her, where I choose her
and run off into the sunset.
- Anybody who sees the three
of us together would be like,
"Sandman, you got to go, man.
"You don't belong with those two.
"Those are two nice,
smart, good looking ladies.
"You're pathetic. Beat it."
But somehow I lucked in
to both of your lives.
So I'm staying there.
- Maybe just the three of
us should do something.
- I would do that.
You just tell me your new schedule, Drew.
When you can do movies now
with the Drew show going on.
- I've really never wanted
to do anything important
in this world and in my life
that isn't a side-by-side with you.
So thank you.
And look out for my love Adam
on what I am sure to be an annual must
in "Hubie Halloween"
streaming on Netflix now.
I love you.
- I love you.
Drew, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I love you, baby.
- Forever
(upbeat music)